good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on strategy
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend friday friday getting
down on friday
welcome back to the morning chest happy
friday everyone jack's here claude here
bruno here thrice here everyone's here
woohoo the streis brothers are back in
town which means that today's episode
will be complete you know
the boys are back in town the boys are
back in town
yeah
yeah is right happy friday everyone we
did it and every single one of us did it
those who earned it those who didn't
those who are good those who are bad
it's friday for all of us actually i
don't think it's friday for our
australian toasters
you know we're huge in australia true
that um two things one
what was one
whatever two is not like other girls
tour is officially on sale if you head
over to girl with no job.com tour
all the shows should be up for sale by
the time you're listening to this the
west coast is 1pm eastern time 10 a.m
pacific time so that's portland in
seattle but shit's getting real you guys
like charlotte is gone charlotte was
gone the minute we went up for sale so
um
that sucks for people who didn't get
tickets but the good thing is is that
i'm playing an even bigger venue in
durham north carolina which i think is
like 90 minutes away so if you weren't
able to get charlotte check out durham
we've got portland seattle long island
new york we've got west hampton new york
we've got all the places nashville the
nashville girlies were taken care of um
girl with no job.com tour i can't wait
to see you all i feel like we have a lot
of new toasters here for so for those
who don't know you're probably like oh
my god i've been listening to the show
claudia and jackie are so funny like
maybe one of them should try stand up
well it turns out one of us did um she's
extremely successful and extremely funny
and she's on tour girl with no job.com
tour it's about a 60 75 minute stand-up
show we're we're laughing we're drinking
we're talking about me we're talking
about my weight we're talking about pop
culture are we talking about the scheiss
brothers i don't think so i think they
got snubbed you know they're not really
in this tour my tour is actually more
like me focused you know yeah but theo
got married
growling
bruno is aggressive
you know what like
they say you know like oh my god bruno
chill the [ __ ] out [ __ ] no no come on
it's friday chill i'm like the boys are
like okay what i was going to say is
like you know there's like a stereotype
like rescue dogs are aggressive and like
if you get a dog from a breeder he's
much safer and you know bruno is kind of
smashing that stereotype that's kind of
aggro he's kind of aggressive no but
here's the thing like he has a big bark
but nobody and he sees himself as this
big macho man maybe because his name is
bruno no man he feels like he needs to
live up to it no i think maybe in the
last couple months he's been entering
like his big brother role and he's been
taking it really seriously he has been
taking it seriously but he does get this
way where he's just like i will fight
anyone at any time and it's like bruno
calm down no one's threatening you
literally this is the meme nobody
bruno you wanna fight you wanna take
this outside this is me nobody bruno
the boys are here it's friday i hope
everyone is feeling joyous i know i am
because
there's really nothing like a friday um
actually there's friday which is a
little bit better but um
i had a few things i wanted to clear up
from yesterday's show oh [ __ ] okay and
then i have something that i want to um
say as well because i saw a comment the
other day being like
who can you explain who all the people
are all the characters in your life and
i would literally love nothing more than
to do that yeah i think like our
newfound success like really hit me
yesterday when you called me to share um
like that i think literally like the
receptionist at your doctor's office was
like oh we recognize your name i watch
you guys on tick-tock she said i love
you guys i watch on tock
and jackie of course called me because
that's like my dream like
some people like to whisper like dirty
things in their lover's ears
when me and ben make love he's like
you're so famous on tick-tock
and that's what takes me to the
edge um but the things i wanted to clear
up from yesterday's episode
first is that um the beyonce toasters
came for us and i have to issue a
correction uncle johnny and i knew this
i don't know i literally just saw a tick
talk about it not a designer uncle
johnny is uh beyonce's uncle and he
recently passed um from hiv but he was
like making dresses for beyonce he made
her prom dress right so i feel like it
has nothing to do with kim nothing to do
with him like maybe she was saying like
her prom dress was made by uncle johnny
and the other girls were wearing cheap
spandex right so so apologize for that
um
not cool claudia not cool um
also we heard from our sewage girlies
yesterday you know we were talking about
manholes yesterday
we did and i said um
you know if you work in the sewage
industry like let me know not expecting
any of our toasters to work in sewage
and there were quite a few and they let
me know that the new um kind of gender
neutral politically correct term for
manhole is maintenance whole that way
the acronym mh stays the same
that's good they don't have to change
signs and
posters
interesting okay maintenance hold and
then the third and final update from
yesterday's show is the rachel's they
showed up and they showed out um we are
getting increasingly closer to our goal
of 100 000 youtube subscribers and how
we're doing that is by basically
targeting people every day and bullying
them into submission so yesterday we
targeted the
rachel's um jackie chose really kind of
a good a good a good name biblical roots
extremely common very millennial um and
today's my day to choose and i've gone
with emily great i think it's super
common so if you are an emily who
listens to this as a podcast
or as a youtube video get your [ __ ]
ass up [ __ ] and go subscribe i know you
have a gmail account that you
catch more flies with honey than with
vinegar actually i think the
the actual lesson we've learned these
past couple of weeks is when it comes to
youtube subscribers bullying works i
think you catch more honey when you call
the bees out by name but still
no i think we need to use a firm hand
okay
emily's this is your time use that gmail
account maybe you haven't logged in if
you in a few years or maybe you have
head over to youtube.com slash your
morning toast and subscribe to help us
reach our goal not that it's a
competition and i'm not pinning women
against women but the sarah's and that
rachel's really she showed up and i
wouldn't want the emilies to you know
forsake their name
i wouldn't want that that would be a big
yikes big yikes
those were all the things i had to
update everyone on great so i'll just do
a brief refresher for anyone who's new
here it's one of my favorite things to
do so my name is shaki this is claudia
we are sisters full sisters same mom
same dad
sisters we have two other sisters olivia
and margo margo goes by snitch if you
ever hear us saying snitch she's the
youngest sister and it's not because she
snitches she does snatch but she doesn't
snitch no and honestly like the roots
the origin of the nickname are just
too too deep to go to get into right now
but we just call her sonation has
nothing to do with like the meaning of
the word snitch now claudia and i are
both married my husband's name is zach
claudia's husband's name is ben olivia's
husband is also named zach confusing but
we call him shapiro sharipo i call him
yeah just depends on the day we also
both have king charles cavalier dogs who
you obviously saw at the beginning of
this episode if you're watching on
youtube my dog's name is theo my dog's
name is bruno but we call him bruce
bryce brassen
um so together they're bryson streis and
they're the streis brothers theo also
goes by thrice he also goes by crunch he
also goes by captain crunch crunchy
angel cringy angel dora right like i
call bryce mostly bryce in these days
but when they're together they're bryce
and stress 100 i call theo like
mostly when it's the two of us i call
them like crunchy or tiggety i also call
theo thea and i call bruno bruna and
then they're the strike sisters
let me be your fiance
i remember the first thing oh but let me
just say for one second because i just
had a few more notes which is that uh
we've been doing the show for four and a
half years now we absolutely love it
it's a dream come true the show we've
been in many different studios this is
now a new studio for us how many has
it's been it was that one this one this
one this is fourth studio yeah
which is really exciting this is the
first time we've incorporated flamingos
and we're really excited about that if
you haven't been able to tell thrilled
um but claudia still lives in new york
so she will be going home soon so that
was my number one is that my time here
has come to an end i'm leaving this
weekend but
there's really not much to worry about
because while next week's episode i'll
be at my studio new york jackie will be
here in florida we have a great new
remote set up you won't even notice the
difference um i happen to be returning
here the week after that because i have
a wedding and i figured like if i have
to be here on thursday for a wedding
like i might as well just come monday
and podcast with you so
it'll be like this a lot back and forth
jackie will be there
and come next monday you're staying with
me right yes
oh my god i'm so nervous so it's just
important to remember like a lot of
people were quaking about all the change
but i hope that these last two weeks
that i've been here have settled
anyone's nerves they've certainly
settled mine i can't lie right um we
have a great florida set up we have a
great remote setup we have a great new
york setup so there's really not much to
worry about if anything like we're
elevating
constantly yeah and now the feed our
feed page is like so pink and it's so
sick and then when you go down it's
green and we'll just
there are a few posts with the blue
couch we're constantly adding to the
vibe and i just i think that's always a
good thing because if you're not
evolving you're dying yeah and so
that's on being alive
true that we've got a great show five
weeks oh and that's the other thing
about us we typically have a great show
yeah and even when like we don't it's
still better than every podcast you've
ever listened to so literally it's and
i'm not even just saying that because
like obviously this is my show it's just
it's an actual fact of life like you can
look it up it's 100 true yeah especially
considering it's everyday right right
like
we're just talented we're feeling
hashtag proud speaking of being proud i
also run a passion project podcast
called the redheads book club it is a
book club we do one episode a month we
read one book i do it with my two best
friends and my little sister snitch and
we all have different book tastes so
every book choice is very different from
the one before and it makes for a great
stimulating convo and people love being
a part of the redheads and the thing is
it's never too late to become a redhead
you can join whenever read the book
whenever listen to the episode whenever
yeah um you know actually i have been
thinking a lot like i have a lot of
jealousy of your passion project i'm
always thinking like maybe i should
start a passion project podcast but like
i literally don't know what about but
you have so many passion projects like
you wrote a book you're on tour like i
feel like you have so you just because
it's not up my past
just because it's not like identical to
my passion project you have i would say
more passion projects maybe that's just
like me and my inherent need to like
have everything that everyone else has i
think it's your need to like be a mogul
never stop yeah never sleep give your
all and so you're like oh wait i'm not
doing another podcast should i be no
you're on tour no you're so right
every time i need to take care of me you
need to yeah you never think about
yourself you never talk about yourself
you never worry about yourself i should
definitely start talking about myself
more maybe i start a podcast maybe
that's what my passion project is about
another podcast and it's called yourself
not to make it about me that's actually
a good name for a podcast trademark it
is but every time you try to start a
podcast like another one you're like i'm
gonna do this sort of podcast with them
i always tell you not to because you
don't have the bandwidth no but okay
really random did you know when you
think of coastal grandmother like this
the name the aesthetic and like the
concept
what do you think like where do you
think it originated nancy meyers
okay like yes but i mean like who coined
the phrase oh someone on tick tock
there's look i actually found her
yesterday i think she might be a toaster
because she followed me on tick tock so
i followed her back her name is lex she
like actually came up with the name and
it's like she trademarked it and so she
was like quaking over that jimmy fallon
video we were roasting yesterday but
like something she made ended up on yeah
the tonight show isn't that cool i never
thought about like and that's the thing
with the internet something becomes so
popular you never think about like who
started it yeah i always think about
that with the girl who started um
eyebrows on fleek yeah i love that video
eyebrows on fleek the [ __ ] that girl was
so funny and then literally it became
just like a part of the vernacular
and nobody even realized she was the
girl who started it yeah and her
eyebrows were on fleek the book yeah
um so i just thought that was
interesting like factoid
we love interesting factoids that's
another thing about us we do
it's not interesting we don't want it
do not send it back return to sender
return to sender immediately
so we've got a great show i have nothing
really else to say except for girl with
no job.com tour um
so yeah what about you i think that's it
for me i think we could jump in if
anything comes up along the way you know
we'll bring it up we will you know we'll
mention it all certainly
so without further ado
do here are the fastest stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
caraway home it's time to ditch the
chemicals with caraway homes non-toxic
cookware and bakeware collections so you
can make healthier cooking a piece of
cake their non-toxic kitchenwares are
all designed for the modern home and
they feature a chemical-free ceramic
coating so food can be prepared with
peace of mind that no hard to pronounce
compound will leech into your healthy
ingredients
so they have the cookware set which is a
modern and chemical free iteration of
the traditional 16 piece set but it's
boiled down just the essentials thank
you by the way not all of us have the
space they have the fry pan saute pan
saucepan and the dutch oven they have
the long-awaited iconix collection which
is the high design upgraded featuring
two unmistakable classic shades both
dressed up in a glossy gold hardware so
obviously like functionally they're
great you know non-toxic but really
aesthetically which is more important to
a shallow person like me they're
stunning the pictures are i mean the
color options are so gorgeous premium
pastel pleni vibes they have the most
gorgeous caraway set and zach whenever
he cooks he like burns everything and
like ruins the pants but these ones are
amazing because they're nonstick and so
he physically can't and it's just a
beautiful thing to watch for ladies with
careless husbands everywhere visit
carawayhome.com
tmt to take advantage of this limited
time offer for 10 off your next purchase
this deal is exclusive for our listeners
so visit carawayhome.com
tmt
or just use the code tmt as in the
morning toast at checkout caraway
non-toxic cookware made modern today's
episode is also brought to you by beauty
counter a leader in the clean beauty
industry with the collective mission to
get safer products into the hands of
everyone they believe that beauty should
be good for you and that's why they
created a variety of clean skincare and
beauty products such as the dew skin
tinted moisturizer which is a daily
makeup meets skincare tinted moisturizer
with an spf 20 it'll provide a sheer
lightweight coverage for a dewy luminous
finish and it helps you achieve an even
looking skin tone and it protects the
skin against the sun's damaging rays i
am a tinted moisturizer girly but i find
a lot of them to be like really oily
make me look really shiny when the
overall goal is obviously like even out
my skin tone give me a little spf so i
can look you know like a human being not
a zombie and i really like the one from
beauty counter it doesn't make me look
oily at all and i feel like it really
protects me from the sun it's just like
a great base that i can do makeup on top
of or not i also really like their
mascara um it's one of their best
selling products it's a clean mascara it
achieves ultimate lift length and volume
without any potentially harmful
ingredients right now they're offering
30 off your first order so in case you
needed another reason to switch to a
clean beauty routine head to beauty
counter and use code toast to save 30
off your first order great thank you so
much claudia
it's a pleasure
thank you so so much you know what i've
noticed like
after i do like the first two ads is
when i usually like to say it's a
pleasure and i notice on fridays you
like
really give me the space because
sometimes you're like thank you claudia
our first story like not not remembering
like i had a song to sing but on fridays
i feel like you're always like
go you know that is interesting
encouraging me to be creative it's like
the fourth friday i've realized that
that is so interesting it might just
because like you're in like a you know a
good friday mood or maybe it's because
the stories are not pressing so take
your time we don't have to jump right in
even though our first story i'm obsessed
with and i'm going to read it verbatim
because kylie jenner i've gotten into a
fight with some loser on instagram okay
i have to say like we'll dive into it
but i did a full deep dive on that guy's
instagram yesterday because i was so
curious like what makes him
in charge the authority right like who
are you
um
so tell the story and then i want to
give my thoughts on this man's instagram
because he's
literally a karen yeah so kylie was in
the lab i think she's in milan she
posted pictures of her like mixing up
some new formulas and you know being
cute in the lab lab tings and this karen
called kj bennett beauty on instagram
posted saying i know the kardashian
generous fans are going to come from my
throat because i'm calling out their
cosmetic queen but what the [ __ ] kylie
i'm a cosmetic developer and work with
cosmetic manufacturers and their labs as
part of my job
i have very short hair and i've never
been allowed into the lab around to the
manufacturing floor without a hairnet
shoe covers masks and disposable gloves
kylie is gaslighting her followers into
thinking she is creating cosmetics and
i'd like to know what ignorant ignorant
manufacturer in italy let her stage this
photo op in their lab and on the
manufacturing floor without following
proper sanitation protocols i need the
name because i want to make sure my
clients never work with them again chill
folks this is not the way folks
[Music]
this is not the way we create cosmetics
and misrepresents how our industry works
credible manufacturers follow strict
sanitation protocols to protect you
hashtag shame on you kylie jenner kylie
responded kevin this picture is not
taken in a manufacturing facility i
would never bypass sanitary protocols
and neither would any other celebrity
beauty brand owner that's completely
unacceptable i agree this is a small
personal space creating my own fun
samples and taking pictures for content
nowhere near the mass manufacturing no
one is putting customers at risk shame
on you kevin for spreading false
information get him kylie kevin shame on
me no shame on you or whoever takes care
of your social media for trying to
gaslight everyone into thinking i'm the
one to blame just take responsibility
for your mistake and move on this is so
full circle because earlier in the week
we were talking about people not
understanding what gaslighting means and
just using it when they like feel angry
about someone they perceive to be lying
that's not what gaslighting is first of
all so i just i hate the misuse of the
word second of all it's important to
note that this office that she's at this
manufacturing office is the same one
that rare beauty uses it's also
important to remember that cody
cosmetics which is literally one of the
biggest beauty conglomerates in the
world owns i think 50
of kylie cosmetics this isn't like some
janky rin of beauty like mixing it up
lip glosses in my kitchen like this is a
really legitimate operation i have a
hard time believing that they would let
kylie into their actual manufacturing
area where people literally make makeup
that gets into the hands of the
customers with her long hair not in a
hair net bypassing all these safety
protocols selena gomez rare beauty uses
this too she was literally in that same
office space not a week ago because
she's in italy with her mans that we
spoke about yesterday
taking videos she was wearing a hair net
like
this is first of all i just i don't
believe that this is the actual place
where they're manufacturing it's not
it's for the content like are you so
stupid i didn't see that and think oh
that's the lipstick kylie's making my
lipstick that i'm gonna put on my lips
like she's [ __ ] around she's taking
pictures she's promoting a brand and
like have you never had a photo op like
have you never taken a picture of you
doing something that you weren't
actually doing no and so then i went on
a deep dive on this guy's instagram and
he's literally like the police he's like
trying to be the diet proud of the
beauty industry yes great analysis like
he is
so annoying like you have to look at his
instagram he's just like karen karen
karen like saying everything every
beauty band is doing wrong and he's
acting as if like makeup is literally
like medical supplies like he's just
acting like they put [ __ ] toxins in
our water like calm the [ __ ] down first
of all it's not that serious first of
all second of all like
literally like who
he needs to do a better job he probably
has like a very you know detailed
background that makes him you know
eligible to be a critic but like i don't
know who or what it is that you do it is
bio is extremely vague like my clients
manufacturing what does that mean what
do you do
i need to know if i can trust you
because
your instagram is extremely vague no
it's extreme loser behavior and i'm just
obsessed with kylie for dragging this
loser i know but i do wish she'd been
making a response and for making the
time to put him in his place and not
backing down he followed up she followed
up but i also think like no one is
really on the side of the stage bennett
beauty right now no but so it's so easy
to like call out a kardashian because
there's always going to be like a slew
of people being like yeah just because
people hate the kardashians and i'm not
even saying this because i literally
would take a bullet for kylie but
because like it's just loser behavior
and i i will never ever take the side of
loser behavior
no this bothered me so much like his i
don't even know what the weight was like
no what's the word when like he's like
so indignant and like condescending and
patronizing like he knows everything
about beauty well actually i would argue
kylie knows a hell of a lot about beauty
she literally
started a billion dollar beauty company
whether anybody likes to believe it or
not you know yeah oh my god it bothered
me so much and then people in the
comments like uh car trashy and like
shut up like if there's a legitimate
critique of the kardashians like i am
the first person to like agree with it
i'm not the first but i will agree with
you but this is not blind loyalty this
is not that she's not like that's it's
not as if her products went out and
kylie hairs were in them right and he's
calling her out like even though i would
literally love her lipstick with kylie's
hair in it i would sell it on ebay right
that's the other thing it's like okay so
kylie contaminated it cool yes
sign me up that's us being blindly loyal
no but it's not that she's taking some
pics calm the [ __ ] down and by the way
if he's such a beauty expert shouldn't
he understand like the importance of
promoting and being authentic on
instagram and like sharing the
experience with your customers here's
where we make this here's my studio like
you're such a beauty expert don't you
know an important integral part of
marketing is promoting on social media
and that's exactly what she's doing so
you should know like more likely than
not she wouldn't
compromise the quality and integrity of
her products for a photo no and casey
neistat selena gomez and kj you've just
given her much more promotion things
right because now we're talking about it
i wasn't going to talk about those lab
pics i saw them they're cute i moved on
yeah and i just don't believe that like
kylie cosmetics which is really like an
extremely legitimate company whether
people like want to drag it or not same
with rare beauty that they would use the
same manufacturer who would allow them
to bypass sanitary rules like i just i
don't believe that they wouldn't they
wouldn't maybe it's like there are some
instagram brands like
that make like lip gloss i'm like yeah
no you're definitely not complying with
safety regulations but i don't feel that
way about
i just don't believe that kylie or rare
beauty would would do that i'm not
worried then he blasted selena too i'm
gonna change my next purchase at kylie
no if anything i'm empowered i've been
hearing a lot of good things about these
creams i want to support this brand
that's under attack right right
supporting small businesses
female owned businesses right right
thanks kj thank you you have to do a
deep dive on his instagram like it will
impact
a little bit of it yeah no it's just
like call out call out please help me go
viral you know it was just like and it's
just so easy i just think that's like a
tacky way to create engagement on social
media like it's just uninspired oh wow
you're an umbrella on the kardashians
nobody's ever thought of that
that's it thank you righteous
indignation
justice for kylie we stand with kylie we
do and she's having like such a cute
weekend at harrods with storm lou
looking gorge gorge gorgeous i loved her
outfit me too multiple outfits she's
killing it we love to see her out and
about again you know she's out and about
like she's all over tick tock which
between her and rach it's convincing but
i'm not gonna do it because i have
scruples the kardashians have really
stepped up on
um tick tock lately do you see you see
this trend where like you tell someone
you're gonna do their makeup and then
you turn them into a minion
i didn't know that was the trend i just
saw kim as a minion north did it to kim
and it was just like everything like yes
trendy queens yeah so i found a solve so
that i can keep up with kylie and all
this premium content i followed one of
her stan accounts that's like kylie's
tick tocks that posts everything that
she does yeah that's good that's good
you should follow one for like all like
kardashian tick tocks because chloe's
been really active too
[ __ ] okay and also that's where i saw
this drama right it was unfold the new
stan account
okay i gotta up my stanhood yeah are you
ready for our next story
by the way did you make um
kelsey owens a story no but let's just
talk about it really quickly she posted
on instagram literally an hour ago
kelsey owens from siesta key do you want
to read it you want me to read it oh
yeah sure verbatim from the horse's
mouth because like you could feel the
fury in her caption but overall she has
been let go or like cut
from um siesta key which is really
shocking
because she's not like a irrelevant
here's what she said last night i was
walking into scene i think that means
they were filming right yeah i was
walking into scene at a freaking strip
club of all places and i was informed
that i will be cut moving forward on
siesta key with absolutely no warning
it's mind-blowing and truly disgusting
that after working on a show since i was
19 years old where i've shared things
about my personal life i wasn't always
comfortable with revolved my whole life
around and put so much effort into could
come to an end in such a disrespectful
manner and so abrupt not even a simple
thank you for sharing the past five
years with us i cried my eyes out then
wiped those tears and filmed my last
scene the best i could with my head held
high despite the way things were handled
i'm so grateful for the friends i've
made once in a lifetime opportunities
i've been given and most of all the fans
i wish i could hug each and every one of
you you have no idea how much your kind
words and support have meant to me and
how much they've helped me get through
some of the toughest times i couldn't
have made it these past five years
without y'all so thank you so much for
that i'm truly a better person my time
on the show may have come to an end but
this is just the beginning for me time
to strut my way into this next chapter
juliet left a comment the crown may tilt
but never falls we've made some amazing
memories and i'll never forget made some
amazing memories i'll never forget
despite the ups and downs love you
forever time to hop on the next roller
coaster girl it's just the beginning
okay so this was kind of shocking um
especially if you know siesta killed
from the early days like it was kelsey
and juliet yeah it's like kristen and
elsie like they were the two pillars of
the show
but
watching it more recently these last few
seasons kelsey like has
herself taken a step back she's not
involved in ever since all that stuff
went down with juliet and also with
kelsey and her bathing suit and there
was like one season where kel and kelsey
said that stuff to sam about julia like
that was the last time i watched by the
way yeah she like she was really
involved in the drama she was starting
stuff and i guess like she didn't like
that version of herself and then the
next season she pulled back completely
to the point where she was talking about
wanting to leave florida like that was
her whole storyline this past season is
that she doesn't want to live in the key
anymore she wants to maybe live in l.a
she was visiting madison and it's like
is madison on the show yes madison is on
the show i'm not caught up on um the la
the most the
rest of this last season but madison has
been going through a lot like in her
personal life yes um
so what's most surprising about this is
that like this wasn't even kelsey's
decision because i would have thought at
some point she would have left the show
on her own because if you want to move
to l.a like that would be that it is
disrespectful the way that they went
about it i think what she's saying i
don't know if she's necessarily even so
mad that she's been cut i think it's the
way yeah like you're about to just
you're they're in miami because i
thought juliet was at 11 so i guess
that's where the scene was being filmed
yeah they're on a uh cash trip probably
and like in the middle of the trip
you're gonna be told like this isn't
your job anymore well they probably
wanted her final scene to be like really
raw and emotional and maybe the best way
they thought of going about that was
literally telling her five minutes
before that you're fired yeah so that's
not cool um as someone who hasn't
watched a show in a while it's like oh
my god they're kicking off kristen
cavallari it's not but it's not because
she herself has just been like much more
withdrawn from the show she stopped even
doing her bathing suit line uh she never
really got back into the drama like she
used to be she just kind of became like
a sounding board for other people and
her personal storyline was like what
will be my journey like should i move to
la florida isn't for me and so
i think like she said ultimately this is
what's best and it is a new beginning
for her and now she can like find what
her passion is and like what makes her
happy
but it must have been a real shock
considering she was that girl season one
no i know and i really haven't kept up
in a while so can you tell me if she
ever made a decision between commercial
and editorial
she kind of chose neither and at the end
of the day she chose commercial because
influencers during the show is very
commercial
but she walked for julia's fashion show
which i loved and that's the picture
that she used so we love women
supporting women and i just wish they
could have supported each other sooner
because
they could have done a bathing suit line
together it does really suck though that
like she was you know
cast and you know
fully like supported by the show when
she was being like toxic drama
and then probably like for her own
mental health she like took a step back
and was like let me just like not be so
dramatic for a minute and then you get
fired it just like reinforces like such
bad behavior but that's literally like
the atmosphere on a reality show like
that yes the only other thing i'll say
about siesta key is there is so many
people on the show who actually aren't
cast members like they're not in the
credits they're
but they're kind of like friend of like
i think it was years before like amanda
even but she was in every scene so i
feel like that could happen with kelsey
if she does wind up staying in the key
where like she'll be on the show all the
time but she's not going to be in the
credits in the beginning you know i
don't want to catch the feeling i don't
really like that on reality shows and i
feel like southern charm is getting that
way we're like i literally can't keep up
with how many people there are they need
to like flush out some of the older
people like seriously why is john
pringle still on the show you know like
is he in the cast thing in the beginning
i don't know but he's still like a
character yeah you know there's like so
many supplemental people that it it's
overwhelming and you can't really focus
they need to like keep the new people
who are really good and get rid of some
of the old people who are like stale
yes but first of all southern charm is
working for me so i'm not gonna complain
but one like sure a new person could be
really good season one maybe even the
whole season but like longevity
longevity you don't know and then you're
stuck with all these people who actually
don't have it versus like the older
people not pringle because he's a new
cast member but the og's like they've
proven that people like them
maybe not every season is going to be
the most interesting for them but like
you need those people to sort of tether
the show yeah i guess yeah
yeah so
surprising i wish kelsey well and i'm
glad that her and juliet are friends
again that was just the one thing that
wasn't working for me yeah it wasn't
right it wasn't right it didn't sit
right no nothing's not real bad but i'm
really proud of juliet and it's so hard
because like i see her on social media
and like she kills she's so she's at
miami swim week she's doing everything
but then like the moments where the
show's filming her she's like making
every bad choice going back to her
x-man's like but that's why she stays
like on the show
she's literally television she drains
her i mean of course like in order to be
so imagine if in order to be successful
professionally you have to be so toxic
personally and like burn everything good
to the ground yep and not focus on
yourself or your well-being or not
drinking like every season like i feel
like so many of the people and every
show they start being like i'm not
drinking but then just the environment
harbors it yeah that behavior and it's
so hard to stick to your goals no that's
why like being a reality star on like
certain shows is so toxic and so
draining and like literally so bad for
your mental health and then years later
you like hear about it because like
they're under contract you're like wow
how did that ever happen but it
literally still happens yeah so
wishing kelsey the best really like i
think this was a great launching pad for
her she's gonna have a successful career
as an influencer um which is good like
it's lo it's more low-key like than a
reality show you know you don't need the
fame you just need to like make a nice
living and live your life and live your
life yeah wishing her the best totally
okay now moving on to the next story
lots of drama
page six is reporting that victoria
beckham is in a cold war with her new
daughter-in-law nicola peltz as
predicted here on the morning toast
because we just felt like there was a
vibe at the wedding it's the ice girls
says page six that's funny there's a
full-on cold war between victoria
beckham and her new daughter-in-law
nicola peltz nicholas helps page six has
learned nicola just married brooklyn
beckham back in april who's their oldest
son but page six years there was trouble
brewing even before the nuptials a
source close to the family told them
quote they can't stand each other and
don't talk the build-up to the wedding
was horrendous the source says that
nicola didn't want victoria to be any
part of the planning and she would
include victoria in on anything
communication was minimal apparently the
cold shoulder didn't help victoria who
was struggling to warm up to the new
family member see her good side
they added that it's become quote
non-stop petty drama and it's coming
between the beckhams who now live in
miami and their son well they haven't
spoken to him much in the last few
months said a source who told us that it
even went over badly at the beckham
house when brooklyn posted a cover of
nicola on the cover of tatler saying
calling her quote the new mrs beckham
i mean that's [ __ ] disrespectful by
the way like that's not cool yeah that
is not cool
okay so obviously we were just like a
little we were tipped off when after the
wedding it was clear that brooklyn and
nicola were going to go by mr and mrs
beckham pelts or whatever yeah um like
new progressive women in power yeah and
every time victoria would post about the
wedding it was mr and mrs beckham so it
was clear that like there was like a
little shade there and i think we all i
mean when you're so famous
so wealthy like
i just can't imagine it being like a
typical ideal mother-in-law relationship
like there's like so much at stake yeah
and there's so many egos like models
singers actresses like there's egos
involved so it's a recipe for disaster
um but i just remember years ago when
they were dating victoria like would
post about her glowingly on her
instagram okay so this is just a theory
but like it's easy to post glowingly
about a nobody do you know what i mean
like for a really long time honestly up
until her wedding like most lay people
who aren't obsessed with celebrity and
social media culture have no idea who
nicola peltz is she's very much like a
social light her dad is like a very
wealthy person
she might i think she's acted but like
no one really knows her work so it's
easy as like you know the biggest star
victoria beckham designer everything to
embrace
someone who's non-threatening yeah but i
think like with the engagement and the
build-up to the wedding they were doing
like all this vogue stuff like i think
like it got like a little too close for
victoria honestly like this is where
egos come into play where it's like
you know for a moment in time
nicola was like the most famous beckham
woman forever that's been victoria so
the way that i perceive it as like a
jealousy thing like a competition thing
that's interesting the way that i
perceive it is it goes back to bella
thorne calling nicola a mean girl yes
and there are a lot of rumors about her
being not a nice person that's true too
i think also nicola and brooklyn are
like obsessed with each other and like
just you know
to the point of ignoring the rest of the
world
and in some ways taking their son away
from the beckham well isn't that just
like the great equalizer the most
relatable thing like i think a lot of
girls struggle with their mother-in-laws
because their mother-in-laws feel like
they're the ones who have always been
there for their sons and the son belongs
to them i'm the number one girl in my
son's life but actually you're not now
and that's where a lot of in-law
relationships between
mothers-in-laws and the bride stems from
it's like a jealousy it's a territorial
thing yeah but like now as a mom like if
someone comes
goodbye no i know are you gonna be a
toxic mother-in-law i don't think so i
it will depend on the girl sorry no
you're right it's definitely easier to
be a mother-in-law when it's your
daughter you know yeah because you would
welcome a man and i'm talking obviously
hetero um relationships it's easy i
think to let a man into your daughter's
life because you welcome the idea of
someone protecting and i mean it's very
traditional of me but those are like
bridal tings like yeah you welcome the
idea of like an addition to the family
someone whose best interest is in your
daughter and like protect joining you
and protecting her yeah um because you
can never have enough protection
but with a mother-in-law and a son
you're not as welcoming to because
you're not coming in to protect you're
coming in to take over to control
to control you know there's only one
[ __ ] in control yeah two [ __ ] because
two [ __ ] can protect and one [ __ ] is
very much in control and i think
brooklyn has gone willingly as he should
by the way um because i don't stand
toxic mother-in-laws who like literally
want to be equal to their lives and be
called mama okay i just saw this guy
this is totally random this guy on
tic-tac was telling a story about how he
was in prison for 14 years and his mom
came to pick him up and it was his
girlfriend at the time so it's not the
same but then his girlfriend drove um to
the prison and so
she showed up and he was so excited and
he's like which one do i drive with and
it was a girlfriend so i do believe you
go with your mom um
okay you just got out of prison your son
gets out of prison
god forbid knock what harry gets out of
prison and you pull up to pick him up
and so does his wife girlfriend you said
you know what i'm saying this is now i'm
saying if it's a wife like
who picks
whose car does he get into
who
the wife if it's a wife and i don't know
why they didn't just drive together
maybe they're coming from different like
states but
you need to communicate better you need
to communicate better i hope i don't
find myself enough of course of course
but the thing is it's like the wife
the wife yeah but that was a girlfriend
that you said
you know it just reminded me of the
situation so it's like when
mother-in-law's can't really understand
that like they now come second yeah to
the wife that's where things get toxic
yeah so brooklyn like
giving you know his all to nicola is
what he should be doing as a good
husband yes but he should also be doing
a better job communicating and there's a
better i do feel like the vibe i'm
getting is that they're very
isolated and just into each other yeah
and it shouldn't be that way he comes
from a really big family and it seems to
be like a loving family he has tons of
siblings like
he shouldn't be his parents are still
married
for it should be one big happy family
agreed completely and by the way in law
relationship things like they take time
dynamics to like settle into place um
but this is not a good start
no but you know what's so crazy is like
when we saw this wedding befo and when
we finished recapping we were like that
was weird about the pelts beckham's
versus her saying the beckhams but the
whole time we were like how perfect how
charmed you know everything is life is
perfect the perfect family the and it
just goes to show you like it's never
what it seems no and we said days of the
week are the great equalizers
mothers-in-law mother-in-laws are the
great equalizers yeah
everyone's got a story no matter how
much money you have where you come from
socio-economic status education and i
also think like yes nicola has like
these stories about her but i think
they're both kind of like tough cookies
you know for sure they're both both like
ice queens yeah and two ice creams
rubbing together
that's more ice very chilly yes
okay are you ready for our next story if
it's a story that's brought to you by
zip recruiter then yes i am
there are so many more things to do
during the summer and you want to free
up as much time as possible to enjoy
them so if you're a business owner the
last thing you want to do is sort
through tons of unqualified candidates
resumes when you could be at the beach
listening to the podcast going swimming
going hiking literally doing a million
things so that's why you need zip
recruiter to find great candidates they
do the work for you now you can try it
for free when you go to ziprecruiter.com
toast here's why zip recruiter is great
it is a resource we have used at the
toast for video editors various like
freelance full-time we've used it and
it's really a great asset they use their
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
you can easily review the recommended
candidates and then invite your top
choices to apply zip recruiter has a
complete suite of tools that makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates four out of five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day so soak
up all that summer has to offer and let
the recruiter do the work for you
go to ziprecruiter.com toast and that's
where you can try it for free again
ziprecruiter.com t-o-a-s-t
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
great thank you our next story
meghan mccain is speaking again about
her experience on the view and
explaining the joy's comment that made
her quit
also
they have confirmed their fifth
co-host and it is ana navarro no it's
both of them it's anna navarro and the
one we talked about last week alyssa oh
oh
they put both of them in megan's place
got it
anyways megan mccain revealed that joy
behar served as the ultimate catalyst to
quit the view the former morning show
co-host explained on a podcast on
thursday that's what
news podcast making news joy's response
to her returning from maternity leave in
january 2021 after giving birth to her
daughter liberty made her realize the
job was not worth it joy as she said
megan said quote i finally went back on
the show and the day i went back on the
show joy said on air quote nobody missed
you we didn't miss you you shouldn't
have come back it was really mean like
that's mama's getting better that was
really mean like i don't they were
arguing about something political i
don't even remember and they were trying
to cut to a commercial break but megan
wanted to like finish her point which
obviously like maybe she shouldn't have
done like you have a certain time slot
but like she was passionate and it was
so mean the way like joy cut her off and
then literally was like
basically get back in the kitchen woman
like it was so
it was so derogatory so i can imagine
that having like a profound effect on
megan
um and i just want to say i didn't so
last night when i saw the ana navarro
thing i'm not really familiar with anna
navarro or like
what her politics are the only thing i
saw is like this really bad take she had
on special needs children it was like
actually really [ __ ] up yeah um
i was trying to understand like because
as far as i'm concerned like megan was
conservative and this is not me being
political at all i just thought the show
was supposed to like represent a broad
range
of political views and then when i
thought it was just on a navarro i'm
like well there isn't actually like a
republican or a conservative so how is
this the view it's just like
of you um
and even with this the other girl who
worked for trump so she's obviously
conservative like
she gets half the seat because ana
vargas the other like i just this is not
me being political like i'm just asking
like how is that like fair
representation for everyone you know
what i mean no i don't and how are we
supposed to have like actual meaningful
dialogue if you're only talking to
people who you agree with right and then
there's just the one that you disagree
with and everything just like megan
right like there really should be
two republicans like actually like
hardcore republicans two like hardcore
democrats and like a centrist or two
centuries sure sure we it should be
spectrum right so i don't i don't know
like how the view intends to like really
represent all of america's views moving
forward if half the time there's not
even like an actual republican on tv
yeah i don't think they're so concerned
you know yeah i think like the way that
they're doing it now um and and even
like this story illustrates that it's
like we liked it better when you were in
here to disagree with that's like really
sad for meghan mccain she said this is
what she said she said um she said i
just started hysterically crying sorry
gentlemen i know i started lactating on
air and started crying she said she went
back to her office and threw up before
calling her brother who convinced her to
leave the show she said quote i didn't
feel supported when i had my baby and i
didn't feel supported coming back and
that was ultimately it that's why i left
so i'm assuming her and joy like aren't
girlies anymore but i am really curious
about her relationship with whoopi
because like the entire time she was on
the show like she really maintained that
like whoopi goldberg was a really good
friend of her father's a good friend of
her family she like has so much respect
for whoopi
um
so is that still true this is what she
said in her memoir quote the thing about
whoopi though is that shields so much
power in culture and television and once
she turns on you it can create
unfathomable tension at the table i
found her open disdain for me more and
more difficult to manage as the years
went on and it became more frequent
occasionally if the show's political
discourse veered into territory that she
found disagreeable whoopi would cut me
off sometimes harshly so
i don't think i don't think it's the
same yeah that's too bad
yeah female friendships notwithstanding
you get to see it i always get like so
interested in this view news i know and
i need to read that book you do women
who punch ladies who punch that makes
the title better because it's like
ladies who lunch except they're me oh
you know i never put that together they
punch each other that's good yeah except
i don't really know the history of the
view but i think i would find it
interesting yeah and i think that's
extremely pertinent because this week on
the view they brought back elizabeth
hasselback for like one day as a guest
co-host to fill in megan's still empty
chair um and a lot of people were
talking about it i don't know what
happened um before i don't know what
happened this week but i just know that
she's back in the news yeah i saw that
too
david
i mean
no but they were also making it seem the
headlines that like she was coming back
and it's like for one day yeah for one
yeah and i think if i remember correctly
it was her versus rosie o'donnell
that sounds right because i follow rosie
o'donnell on tick tock and she made a
tick talk about the elizabeth hasselbach
she's like i went to watch um elizabeth
hasselbeck's episode and now i remember
why i hate her or something like
it was um it's obviously not resolved
between the two girlies damn and just
makes me upset i feel like i said this
earlier like i feel like the view is
supposed to be like we can all have
difference of opinions and still be
friends and time after time like they've
proven that actually not to be true yeah
so it's upsetting it's setting a bad
example yeah it really is actually yeah
our next story is some big news from
lady a they're postponing their tour to
support support charles kelly's journey
to sobriety
oh i think this is good
lady i is postponing their request line
tour in solidarity with band member
charles kelly's sobriety journey quote
we are banned but more importantly we're
family
the country music trio wrote in a joint
statement on social media on thursday
quote we're proud to say that charles
has embarked on a journey to sobriety so
right now in order to be the healthiest
strongest and most creative band we can
lady a will take time with the support
of our families and team of
professionals to walk through this
together
i love this by the way because two
things there have been you know whispers
in the country community for years about
um his struggle like his open struggle
with alcohol and not really any
resolution but also i think that
honestly like when i think of the
trajectory of lady a's career um
when they first had like those first
couple songs that were literally like
cross genre hits everyone whether you
like country or not i just need you now
like they were gonna be like the next
dan and shay almost and it does feel
like they got
like sidetracked and almost kind of
blown off the radar and i think a lot of
it had to do with like the toxic
dynamics of the group that were fueled
by his drinking that's like what i think
and this is like i think like a 10-year
issue um and i love charles kelly he's
literally so hot i actually take a
bullet for him so i'm so i'm actually
really happy to hear this and that
they're sharing it openly is like really
cool because a lot of people in this
industry like struggle with addiction
they like get help but we never hear
about it right but they are on tour so
they would have to come up with a reason
right postponing they could always say
like covid like you could come up with a
million things yeah they did say it was
early days of his sobriety journey so i
think he has a long way to go but i
agree i think this is all good news and
i do
they have they're so successful and
country fans love them and they do huge
tours and their music's on the radio and
i don't think they are lacking in any
successful department no me neither but
along the way they have each done solo
endeavors
i feel like sometimes the band always
wasn't a priority they don't have like
the the crossover success that they
maybe could have had as you're arguing
and maybe some of these dynamics did
play a part in that i think them
prioritizing their solo projects at
least the vibe that i got and i don't
know this for a fact had to do with like
the band being a little toxic needing a
break eating a break and like tiptoeing
around this big thing everyone's
thinking it but no one's saying it yeah
it's like if dan of dan and shay when
did a solo project i'd be like okay
something's going on right not great
right and that's kind of what's going on
with um florida georgia line but they're
i mean yeah they're like broken up but
not i don't know what's going on
yeah i mean
aside from us
you know p some people like need a break
from each other like duos and maybe
that's why you should only work with
your sister but then you look at the
jonas brothers big yikes yeah because
then if like if you you know
professionally things get weird they
also get weird personally and like your
whole life falls apart like yeah at
least if you're in a band it doesn't
work out like you still have your family
so like my working theory was like you
know because they're not family and it's
just you know at a certain point you can
be super close and work together but
there's always something i call her
daddy you know right by the way it
always comes back to right and then i
always think about us and it's like oh
we have to be tethered because we're
family and so we have to [ __ ] make it
work even if you know if for some reason
it didn't but then i think about the
jonas brothers and they throw a wrench
in my theory i know but i do believe the
jonas brothers are like an outlier i
like to think
i mean let's think of like you know
bands they didn't get it back together
and maybe if they weren't family they
would have had no reason to they
wouldn't have but kevin started having
kids and it's like we're not going to
know our uncles family like tethers you
two to one another and in some actually
i don't think they really would have
ever gotten back together if they
weren't brothers because first of all
they had no reason to come back to one
another and they were having individual
success like dnce and nick jonas's solo
career yeah so they would have continued
on with that and all been fine yeah
so
family man caroline manzo said it best
blood is thick in the water it's really
true
so true so true our fifth and final
story is brought to you by zocdoc it is
real reviews before you book a brunch
spot you pour over a list of reviews
don't you so why don't you do the same
when you're booking a doctor with zocdoc
you can see real verified patient
reviews to help find the right doctor in
your network and in your neighborhood
after all finding the right doctor is
just as if not import more important
than finding the right place for eggs
benedict and i feel like especially like
you know everyone gets in a routine when
it comes to doctors but you just moved
like you don't know anything just about
to say that like when you move it makes
you realize like you need new everything
new everything and yeah what's the yelp
for doctors sock doc so on zocdoc you
can find every specialist under the sun
whether you're trying to straighten your
teeth fix your achy back get a mold
checked out anything else zocdoc has you
covered their mobile app is as easy as
ordering a ride to a restaurant or
getting delivery to your house you
search find and book doctors within a
few taps you can find and review local
doctors read verified patient reviews
from people who actually made
appointments and now when you walk into
the doctor you're actually beautiful
now when you walk into doctor's offices
you're all set to see someone in your
network who gets you go to zocdoc.com
find the doctor that is right for you in
person or remotely so zocdoc.com toast
download the zockdoc app for free when
you use the link
zocdoc.com toast you will get zocdoc
downloading the app for free starting
your search for a top rated doctor today
many are available within 24 hours
zocdoc.com
toast great our fifth and final story a
little update something we've been
talking about um not officially but
brittany griner has devastated after a
russian court sentences her to nine
years in prison lawyers say i saw this
and i'm
like
this is like so upsetting yeah well at
first i thought like
i mean she has been sentenced to nine
years and it's in a russian penal colony
so that's where she's going but this
does still leave things open to a
prisoner exchange yeah so i mean i feel
like um there's not really like clarity
in like what anyone is actually planning
to do and i guess maybe like they're not
sharing top secret government [ __ ] with
us um but i would like to know like if
there's a plan in place brittany
griner's wife is like kind of the face
of the social media campaign she's been
like
literally begging the president to
actually do something um
and now i think it just like feels real
for a lot of people because she's kind
of been in this limbo like appealing and
you know in court but now she has like a
full ass sentence and it's really
[ __ ] long for a marijuana pod like
it's so dumb
um and i don't know like what the plan
is to get her out like people are saying
they want to trade this like crazy ass
violent russian arms dealer who's like
in guantanamo or something here um
putin's like yeah give me him and you
can have her which is like that sucks
but you got to do what you got to do
like you had to bring girly home
yeah and apparently now this is like
bringing out other
stories of americans there's like and
i'm completely uneducated so like just
bear that in mind there's this other guy
in russian prison american his name is
like adam and like no one's talking
about him they're like get adam out too
damn so it's just so scary also you had
said that
for a while the media wasn't really
covering this because they were like
trying to do a backdoor deal or
something and not like make it a big
deal so that like russia doesn't know
how much we want her back right like not
like quaking over how big of a deal this
is because then russia's like wait this
is a big deal like we want all of our
disgusting russian arms dealers back you
know so not letting them know what they
had so because i was like why the [ __ ]
is nobody talking about this like and
everyone keeps comparing like if it was
lebron james the biggest player in the
nba not the wnba like he would be home
already um so i was like yeah wait why
isn't anyone talking about it and then
when i had posted that on my instagram
it was like the same day this podcast
came out um basically like the media was
told like not to blow it up yet because
it might impact negotiations which did
actually make sense to me yeah but i do
feel like now now it's like we gotta
blow it up and
it might impact negotiations i know and
the thing is but are there negotiations
the way they were doing it before didn't
work either
right and i don't even know if like
anyone is actually trying to get her out
like all everything i hear is just like
conjecture like how do you know what the
government foreign affairs national
security is trying to do
yeah the secretary of state said that
quote grinder was quite happy to know
that she had not been forgotten and that
there were some possible developments so
vague i know she just must be like
freaking out yeah like so scared yeah
we'll keep you abreast but i really do
hope she gets home safely and i think
like everyone should be like quaking
over this because
it's so sad like she must be freaking
out so scared yeah you know it's really
like being in prison is obviously scary
no matter what like in a foreign country
where like you don't speak the language
really scary um
so those were the fast five stories you
definitely needed to know them like all
of them i i feel like you did was a
little six because of kelsey right five
and a half kelsey was the sixth man six
man
um and that's our show this is the final
episode of the week and it's the final
episode um that i'm down here but again
if you missed it at the beginning of the
show i'm literally coming back a week
from today so don't worry
and it gives us a week to work to like
show you guys what we have brewing for
remote yeah and get our kinks worked out
yeah in the remote studio so um i'm
gonna be in west hampton on friday for a
show so girls no job.com tour are you
gonna go see tom sagura and tim dillon
they're both playing like the day before
and the day after like a weekend of it
if i was in town i would go to all three
you just sleep there triple whammy my
favorite podcast and jay leno you
i'm good you guys would
i would have a festival called pogchella
and it was just like me going to the
three of you we should have a festival
called i mean i'm sure there i think
there is like podcast festivals but like
we've never been invited so they're
obviously not good um we should put
together like podcello i think we were
invited to one really oh we actually
were yet yeah but it didn't but it
wasn't a podcast festival it was a
comedy festival that we couldn't like
schedule it didn't work but i don't know
if there's like an actual podcast
festival yeah
like but who would put it on that's the
thing that's the same thing with like
the podcast awards it's like oh who
should put it together iheartradio then
they only nominate their own podcast
which obviously makes sense like if we
did awards i would nominate tnn i'm
actually shocked iheartradio hasn't done
a podcast festival of their podcast i
don't expect them to include us right
like live shows
of their podcasts podfest
yeah they would call it i heart podcasts
you know i don't think you're actually
allowed to like put together a festival
and have it end in chella like i think
it's trademark of course i mean i would
assume yeah no they would call it i
heart podcast but we would call it podca
yeah that's why we're better than
everyone and that's why we'll get sued
and that's why it'll never happen
um thank you guys so much for listening
to the show have an amazing weekend love
you all don't forget to subscribe on
youtube thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast the millennial
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast anywhere anywhere absolutely
anywhere there's nowhere that we're not
where you could find a podcast where you
couldn't find ours any other podcast
give me facts so that's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i heart radio cast
box all the places so wherever you
listen to podcasts find out some morning
toast and leave a five-star review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
have an amazing enclave weekend and
we'll see you guys
on monday in crab though keep it in
crayon bye nothing less than in crab
y'all bye